researchers at the University of
Bradford are developing a simple
universal blood test to diagnose cancer
and a baseball team in Korea now allows
fans to cheer through a computer and
have it physically represented at the
stadium by a robot Vsauce Kevin here
this is mind blow
geebo is the first robot that will be a
part of your family designed by famed
robot asses cynthia brazil Gebo is an
interactive companion and helper it
comes with several apps including one
that takes pictures using a facial
tracker a personal assistant that keeps
your schedule and provides reminders a
telepresence app for long-distance
communication and even a storyteller
that uses sound effects and graphics to
entertain kids the crowdfunding campaign
aims to create a community of developers
using geebo as a platform in order to
maximize the potential of the social
robot planning to roll out in 2015 one
of the longest pieces of dinosaur
coprolite recently sold at auction for
$8,500 coprolite is fossilized poop in
related news newly discovered tracks add
to the theory that t-rex is hunted in
packs which is terrifying the world's
largest laser is helping researchers
study planet formation by crushing
diamonds the 30 foot long laser along
with 175 other lasers combined to exert
50 million times the amount of Earth's
atmospheric pressure on a single diamond
and they're doing this to learn what the
core of huge planets like Saturn might
look like since is a bid site monitor
and smart alarm that kind of turns
sleeping into a video game it uses a
sensor clipped onto a pillow to monitor
the bedroom environment and how well you
slept and then gives you a score so if
the room is pitch-black you gain points
but if a car alarm woke you up at 3 a.m.
you lose points with the smart alarm
function if you're supposed to be up at
9:30 but you're awake at 9:15 it'll go
off so you don't fall back asleep waking
you up at the optimum time the recently
unveiled mercedes-benz future truck 2025
drives itself it's equipped with the
highway pilot assistance system that
drives completely autonomously up to 85
kilometers
our the prototype was tested on a
stretch of the Autobahn near East
Germany and responded perfectly to
traffic but it retains a steering wheel
for critical maneuvers and they hope to
have them on the road by 2025 largest
aquatic insect recently found in China
with a 21 centimeter wingspan that's a
point two inches a new study shows that
fist-bumping transmits significantly
fewer bacteria than shaking hands and
nearly twice as many bacteria are
transmitted during a handshake compared
to a high-five
researchers say the fist bump could
substantially reduce the transmission of
infectious diseases between people
finding Rover is an app that uses facial
recognition to help find lost dogs users
take a front-facing photo of their dog
and if some day it gets lost the app
scans all the missing dogs in the area
conversely you can help return lost dogs
by snapping a photo and matching the
face and getting the owners contact info
researchers at Carnegie Mellon have
created a camera filled dome that
recreates full 3d motion scenes the
two-story geodesic dome features over
500 cameras capturing 100,000 different
points in motion at anytime without the
need for physical markers this could be
a huge upgrade to motion capture for
movies and video games and even
eventually be used in sporting events
and concerts by taking advantage of the
crowd cell phone cameras finally center
of the Sun is synced with glitch
animation representing the lifecycle of
an Olmec Sun God
I'm going to leave you with a MacGyver
robot that uses environmental objects as
tools and as always thanks for watching
you